(light acoustic guitar)
♪ Me and Jesse's cousin
♪ Went to the Chevron after work
♪ To grab a couple sixers
♪ And some beefy jerk
♪ The man behind the counter
♪ He said he'd like to see ID
♪ I handed him one of a guy
♪ Who sort of looked like me
♪ He frowned and asked
me what was my address
♪ I knew the street but I
couldn't quite get the rest
♪ I said I'd lost my real ID
♪ And that we would
pay him double
♪ We swore that we
weren't cops and that
♪ He wouldn't get in trouble
♪ He smiled and said
♪ I'm sorry, but
it's already 12:04
♪ And the state says
it's too late to sell
♪ Alcohol anymore
♪ Sadly we went to
put back the beer
♪ But then a bottle
caught my eye
♪ And I got an idea
♪ What about mouthwash
♪ What about huffin' paint
♪ You don't need ID to buy it
♪ And you can't arrive too late
♪ What about mouthwash
♪ What about smelling glue
♪ If they say you
can't buy liquor
♪ Then some cough
syrup should do
♪ Before we count this
night up as a loss
♪ What about mouthwash
♪ Sittin' in the truck
in the parking lot
♪ Underneath the moon
and all them stars
♪ We don't need
their liquor stores
♪ And we don't their bars
♪ Drinkin' Listerine and tonic
♪ And Jesse's cousin
sipped a Scope and Coke
♪ A Robitussin Redbull
♪ Now that shit ain't a joke
♪ But something changed
within me at that store
♪ Beer and spirits just
don't cut it anymore
♪ The whispers that I hear
♪ And the looks
that I keep gettin'
♪ When I toast with
a Dimetapp daiquiri
♪ At a fancy wedding
♪ And last night a
cop pulled me over
♪ Goin' down 95 south
♪ And he saw the
Sherman Williams
♪ All over my nose and mouth
♪ He just looked straight at me
♪ With a pity in his eyes
♪ Like he'd just seen
the depths of sadness
♪ That man can't have inside
♪ And the lengths
to which he'll go
♪ To numb it down
for another day
♪ He looked as if he'd cry
♪ But then he just walked away
♪ I watched as he drove
off down the interstate
♪ And then I thought to myself
♪ That's another reason
this stuff's great
♪ What about mouthwash
♪ What about sniffin' glue
♪ When the police pull you over
♪ They ain't sure what to do
♪ What about mouth wash
♪ Or even hand sanitizer
♪ When they check
your glove compartment
♪ They won't be none the wiser
♪ Before we count this
night up as a loss
♪ Say what about mouthwash
♪ What about mouthwash